so one time like we were having sex i
was telling him to spank me right he's
like are you sure like i don't want to
hurt you and i'm like yeah cause i'm
thinking sex bank right
there's not the bellagio then he goes
okay and he went what and i just started
crying i'm like bro what the [ __ ] is
going on damn it's like her head smashes
into the bellagio glass through the wall
oh yeah
just troubleshooting jill's like i like
rough sex he goes i got you bro
you put the mouthpiece on no i felt so
bad like we're like doggy style on the
floor right we mean we i spanked her i
never seen anyone crawl away doggy style
that fast boom and then she was like
and then she turns around she's crying
and i have a boner i'm like oh [ __ ]
and i'm like oh my god what happened
it's like one of those cartoons where
she runs in place and then takes off
and then i think afterwards i was like
are we gonna continue and she's like are
you stupid
we figured it out it's been a lot it's
been many years we got it